how difficult is this i mean everything
even earth is moving in space how hard
is this to do well Emily the difficulty
of this cannot be overstated this is
really an extremely exciting day and the
European Space Agency with the Rosetta
spacecraft and the feel a lander just
accomplished an extraordinary feat and
it's still playing out the the lander
just made its way to the surface of the
comet only hours ago and it's right in
the middle of its science mission
returning its first data so what kind of
data you're looking for what what to you
is going to teach you about what you're
trying to do with your business this is
the first time in history we've actually
had something that was designed to go
down to the surface of one of these
small bodies of comets and asteroids and
really study its surface so from
planetary resources we are interested in
the resources of space particularly
things like water and hydrogen and
oxygen and of course that's where comets
get their tails from so well fillet is
actually going to be uncovering is just
what is a comet made out of and what is
it structuring and what is that surface
like we've seen it in the movies for a
very long time but today we're actually
seeing the real thing playing live out
this morning this was done by the
European Space Agency what about NASA
should we be concerned that NASA didn't
do this well nasa has had other missions
to comets and NASA actually has a number
of instruments on the spacecraft
orbiting the comet but Europe does get
european space agency does get most of
the credit for this extraordinary
success NASA's plans also include going
to 22 asteroids in the future they'll be
rendezvous at an asteroid just next year
and also returning a sample from one but
it's not just the u.s. either the
japanese space agency the indians the
Russian even the Chinese actually just
returned a mock mission for the moon so
space exploration and our understanding
the solar system is really growing to be
more than just United States effort and
what we're excited about is more than
just a government effort this is a thing
that private businesses are now getting
do as well yeah to that point the
orbital sciences launched was it last
week and the explosion on the launch pad
I was shocked Chris to read the next day
that you had something in that spaceship
that didn't make it to space talking
about what kind of a setback that was
for you and where Planetary Resources
stands right now as a result of that
explosion yeah our first spacecraft that
our team built the arcade 3 which is a
prototype of what we're using for
asteroid prospecting technology was on
that rocket that didn't make it that far
off the pad last week but for us it's
disappointing but it's really part of
the game these things happen and if you
don't plan for them you absolutely don't
know the business so we're actually
already scheduled with our next
spacecraft for our next launch
delivering it next summer just 10 week
10 months away from right now